citizens of the reject Nation we and by we I
mean the real Aaron Alexander give this man
a follow are here to return for the follow-up
film Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Out of the
Shadows now I know we weren't the biggest fans
of the prior installment to this one we were not
the things we appreciated though right there
are things we appreciated about it yeah yeah
appreciate it a little bit more than you I think
well you know I appreciate it I didn't I hate it
I just thought it was aggressively made these are
some things there's some nice things for sure for
sure the common thing that I've heard people say
is that the follow-up this one is a better one
so I feel like we should watch it going with an
open mind and judge for ourselves if we like it
more than the last one we'll see we just gotta be
honest at the end of the day we gotta be honest
but ladies and gentlemen what do you prefer this
one leave it down in the comments below yes this
is one of those things Aaron has never seen this
one I've never seen this I'm pretty sure I did
see this one time uh yes I don't know the plot at
all yep don't know if I can give a slight spoiler
but I feel like it's because I saw that in a
compilation of honest trailers that
there is a sky beam in this movie
the last one ripped off the Spider-Man
movie but this one's gonna rip off every
other comic book yeah we'll see
well who knows who knows who knows
but ladies and gentlemen we're after a great
start leave a like on this video thank you
to prepper for editing down these reaction
highlights and as always full interaction
watch long were you single with your own copy of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Out of The Shadow
available for our super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page as always we cover several
things there exclusively reaction highlights
and watch Longs included let's get to it people
[Music]
did they do that in the first one I
don't think so no we got some ninja
stars in the opening okay I like
that off to a good start all right
getting creative it's better guys
it's a better movie 10 out of 10.
oh there they are then Turtles fellas
it's go time Turtles on the top
[Music]
what happened to Turtle formation I
thought you said why would he say s what
yay we're starting with them yay
yeah cool
Donny here we go that was a really fun opening I
like this this is a really fun opening yeah man
steal it yeah look how that delivery man is
just used to delivering the pizza that way
gotta show up at this corner every
night let's get that box from Mikey
that's a whole reintroduction right this was a
totally different tone what the hell I love this
how are you guys not ruining the pizza right
I feel like it's gonna get smushed
where's the cheese staying in place
of the bottom of that box what's going on here
yes this already feels way more like the turtles
Right a million times better instantly that's
it's in the house right here anyone can sit
down there he saved the city we should be on
the Jumbo Tron not in it what's the point Fair
Point rough along with his army of enforcers the
Foot Clan Shredder ruled our streets until
one day from out of the Shadows stepped a
Beacon of Hope who's gonna get the credit was
just a humble cameraman oh this guy no way
single-handedly battled Shredder locking him up
behind bars no what that's not the Shredder from
the first one later this week we'll receive
an honorary key to the city please welcome
oh what a bunch of [__] wow you changed man
you changed you sold out bro do the turtle's
under the bus well the truth is Jill I
actually had helped a couple of friends
no way he's totally gonna give his props no
he's not he's not thunder and lightning ah
you suck you know we couldn't take credit for
bringing down Shredder Vern's just sticking
to the arrangement we made with him what's the
point of doing something if you don't get credit
I'm only in it for the glory god oh be
careful with that that's my pea shooter
you got to say [Laughter] an example one minute
it's a ninja aim right you got this
[Laughter]
why is no one trying to wipe it off right or
telling him right at my grand central station's
taking out Dr Baxter Stockman oh Baxter Stockman
he graduated MIT at 15 he's got 134 patents he's
the lead scientist for tcri Tyler Perry I think
Baxter Stockman is working Shredder do you need us
there no Baxter is a softy she's like a spy right
CIA agent super spy I want to use it to join hack
into Baxter's emails your watch needs to be within
three feet of his device iPad iPhone whatever
here you are sir yeah I'm vibing with this one
much more already yeah instantly we'll see how
it goes but we're currently early currently
vibing with it better already yeah you don't
know who I am your back's just documented truly
inspirational for me I'm so sorry I'm just like
I'm a nerd no please I'm a nerd she's got
a Medea fetish it's the difference between
like Lord of the Rings and Harry Potter
or um TED talks and Comic-Con [Laughter]
at every step of the way so I have to take this
really quick it's my boyfriend
I'm sorry oh you have a boyfriend
Halloween what's going on here
oh is she gonna do Action Hero change okay
Action Hero change put the yellow jacket
on I think she's jacking the outfit
she's just eyed right no she has to
put her she has to put her official suit
on okay it'll perfectly fit don't worry
sure you take the wig off okay school girl yep
Jennifer's Body I was just thinking the
same thing look everybody I got a cowboy
[Music] I love how that guy just let
his hat get stolen right oh she's hot
oh wow defense don't let the
pizza slide into the core
Mikey that's the last slice come on [Laughter]
someone's gonna eat [__] on that pizza
oh no way corniest piece on my Nike it's
Pizza look at it look at my shoe oh my God
it's a Nike advertisement he's on my Nike
hey man that's CGI slice I'm sorry we're
just gonna act like that's a normal thing
that happens in professional basketball
we're gonna have to find a new spot to watch
the game now Mikey Mikey I mean they're not
gonna know for a show the stay of the Dead
David dead it's like the one night of the
year where we fit in Mikey we're ninjas
we live in the shadows let's go let's go
I just really feel like that I'm not I'm not
just sitting here to say it the personalities
just feel a lot more boisterous yeah yeah because
they're actually the leads of the movie this time
and look how real that looks [Music]
Transformers ah cool Baxter is working
with the Foot Clan Shredder is being
transported to a prison in Upstate
New York tonight and the Foot Clan
are planning on hitting the Convoy
goddamn foot Clint he'll be free again
who Donnie tretter the shredder definitely
getting soft reboot Vibes out of this 100
because yeah they took themselves so seriously
and they're trying to be all dark and gritty with
that first one rather than embracing it with
like the weird sci-fi Tech and like actually
casting an actor for Shredder this time around
oh it's that oh the wrestler guy Sheamus yes
[Music]
is this a different actor than the first one
it's 100 a different actor we never even saw
his face yeah we did remember kind of like it
was kind of it was in the shadows but they're
like oh we're not too sure about this because
they're actually I read some oh this is so Arrow
what up big daddy lawbreaker he's
the people's champ of Sac right here
you have meditated for nearly 24 hours
in 10 seconds you will reach nirvana
does somebody want to explain Sensei the
Foot Clan are attempting to make shredder
out of custody the effects look so much better
especially on him they read they did a remodel
on on Splinter there okay guys don't get
too excited it's still a work in progress
oh bumblebee turtle tank
all these wires are still cool Tech upgrade yeah
with the sewer cap on top
I love that don't recline
neat Donatello actually doing some cool
inventions you got 32 counts of first degree
murder God damn you my friend seriously
need a hobby I myself am a hockey guy ah
hey Mr Shredder big fan of your work especially
your Rarity stuff my name is Bebop this is rocks
what works in mysterious ways donut Shredder now
you get to spend the rest of your life behind
bars or not I feel like he's like pitching up
his voice a bit to sound like younger Stephen
Amell yeah definitely it's got a nicer guy
tone coming up on our right and our left
come on man go go go go go go go
damn this feels like GI Joe
oh my god oh cool that's pretty dope
man they really blew those cars up huh
for real that's some real destruction right there
is an effective ass car chase we're being ambushed
heading north on 87 we need immediate backup oh
how fun I wouldn't want to participate
in a breakout Heist like this come on
come on with the three-wheeled
car motorcycles come on this
is awesome I'm having a lot more
fun yeah it's way more fun [Music]
we're the Shelf they're in the back what the
hell are they doing in the back creating an
obstacle for you I hope when he said where were
the shells that's when the turtles show up I
would have liked that they're trying to make him
a little bit like Bruce Willis and die hard try to
make him John mcclainish I can see that yeah you
see it ah the turtles they're the shells [Music]
oh my God sweet sauce that is deadly you
almost killed Casey right nunchucks giganticus
it's like a serious Transformers
say hello to my little friend
pretty cool effects pretty
cool facts yeah [Applause]
why not guys they're coming back enough
it's time to take out the trash Turtle
style let's go let's go rap let's go
that's how I roll that's how you
roll let's go [Music] ah surfing
a motorcycle so awesome move in
Get Him to the extraction point
oh this is a well-constructed car chase
yeah it's a very entertaining yeah action
scene kinetic but I can keep up with it too
yeah exactly so everything's going
on it's not too muddled [Applause]
how is that safe for him to be there
[Music]
he's so long to shoot right
good start work here look at this man this is
good right I can't get over it I feel like they
got an entirely different creative team for this
one they must have we have to teleport Shredder
earlier but you said yes teleport Shredder I'm
not gonna question it yeah we got that Tech now
knocking on one shot is all you got to not
miss your chance initiate take the shot Mikey
yeah let's go full sci-fi I'm
down teleportation abilities
this is not very realistic for my Turtles movie
that's right yes I remember that now yep that's
yes oh my God I don't remember looking this
disturbing oh of all the ways you guys excuse
me but that would require you I'm thinking me
and no one no thing is smarter than the
cry I do not remember this design at all
it's so slimy you had your buddy Dr Stockman
found something of mine oh my God it's so
gross upon entering your atmosphere it broke
apart into three pieces sweet another is in a
museum in New York of course it is Rainforest
and rainforests it's a museum two locations it
will open a portal through which I could bring
my War Machine the Tetra drone to Earth okay
okay this is definitely an early 2010s plot oh
yeah what is he he's like he's an alien right
problems with those pests
oh look back in oh his eyeball I popped
out of it I do like how uncomfortably
disturbing it's real ripples [Laughter]
it's all slimy and like drippy too yeah
kind of residue from a teleportation event yeah
teleportation event residue man it's the worst
totally Plug and Play perfect I'll go check it
out we'll go with our brain support even the
Turtle sewer Hideout is brighter and when
hourly updates from Homeland Security and
border patrol make it on the half hour excuse
me this is my investigation now bureau chief
Vincent organized crime sweet two female lead
detectives this movie was woke before woke
existed [Laughter] ninjas on motorcycles just they
come zipping past and they're coming at us Giant
it's taking me a long time to get acclimated
to his performance you're so used to seeing him
as like arrows you're so goofy thanks for
your statement Jones that's officer Jones
and I'm gonna be a detective someday
what did you say well they Infuse the
hockey element of Casey into this I hope so
so you two idiots have a favorite bar you
don't have to be stupid enough to go back there
yeah they will of course they will yeah they are
my man my man did they not mutate in this movie
do you know I think they do yo guys how special
I love this guy that time a side of pickles no
are these pickles untraceable those phones are
hard to track and Shredder himself oh he looks
familiar he's in 30 Rock in Brooklyn Nine-Nine
and John Wick I'm tired of being someone else's
errand boy maybe even start our own foot plan
I mean honestly how hard could it be sweet
shot yeah oh my God gone with the mecca suit
thank God he's not looking for
partners I'm looking for Aaron Moore's
we could work with that I'm looking for turtles
also I feel like the music tracks in this fit
track way better yeah the last one they kind of
felt a little forced at times this actually Vibes
well with the movie tapped it well to the the
vibe of the scenes I agree do not let this setback
distract you as long as you keep the team Unified
you shall always succeed that's the lesson
you sure those guys didn't come through here
hey Bill I don't know what you're talking
about drinking on the job I love this song
and listen hey what are you doing uh you know
what never mind it has a scratch on it damn
it holy crap look at the skills of this guy I
slipped them cell phones that's all I know and
I imagine a responsible business person wouldn't
sell Hardware without a means by which to track I
have a GPS this guy's cave again so easily right
I just realized the Vanilla Ice thing is a it's
a fun Easter egg because Vanilla Ice is in the
second 90s movie yeah you did uh go ninja yeah
I feel like if I saw Megan Fox in
person I would explode [Laughter]
spontaneously combusted which doesn't happen I
know just just freak out like I would be like
those four brothers are still out there
we need to create soldiers that could defeat
them with a single blow and this will help us
do that guy shredder actually has a personal
fear against the turtles stopping him yes
I completely thought Shredder was not
in this movie um yeah yeah I had no clue
foreign but I like that he's actually a
person in this one yeah because I feel
like this one like outside the
Wilderness thing I don't think
you need to watch the first one
to get this one deal with this
this is when they be okay this makes sense
yeah I'm Gonna Keep Them human
they know what the people want
that's things not in a good way ah
whoa trippy visual all right oh mutation
mutation the key to our Evolution I wonder
if they always start off as people are
you or most of the time whoa [Music]
this is like a body horror transformation dude
wow man it's like full-on horror movie
monster transformation this feels funny
aren't your clothes like just rip off at that
point Let's Get Like You Gotta Get Like mutant
sized clothes for you okay if the hole can keep
it on man they can you're not wrong about that I
knew it it is a really smart cop inside every
human there's a dormant Gene which ties us to
our animal ancestors you're a rhinoceros and
you're a I don't know what you were warthog
[Laughter]
O'Neill get that canister
oh smooth sliding foreign
yeah get that mask on
this really does look like the GI Joe's
movies too with the black and leather and
stuff yeah I see it whoa whoa you guys don't
really wanna do this again right it doesn't
usually work out well you should have given
the turtles a heads up at the turtle alarms
oh he's using the hockey pucks instead of the guns
that he probably owns as a cop no
why is he resorting to this side
because fan service
bad hockey stick is really strong
oh where'd it go [Laughter] that was funny
[Applause]
I'm having fun with the KC inclusion
simultaneously is one of the things I feel
the most tempted to criticize it doesn't exactly
make sense it's not Dragon yeah Casey Jones
hey well
do not eat us [Laughter] they're my
friends yeah Donatello over there and
the purple he's a technical genius who
is technically Raphael over there in
the red he's like a big cuddly teddy
bear he's in the blue fearless leader
silent but deadly and I'm at glance take
a laugh track I love this music with it
you have eyes on Bebop and Rocksteady what do you
care about those two well let's just say that I
have a vested interest in bringing them to justice
grab Friday the 13th here at follow nice nice
laughs
yeah we've uh seen them around here before gotta
go hard leaving you Casey Jones it's all you bro
[Laughter]
giant rat one new guy zero you know I was doing
just fine tracking Bebop and Rocksteady and then
you just T-boned my existence it doesn't
make sense why this version of him would
have a mask you have a gun you go up against
these ninjas [Laughter] who are these guys
these four have done more for this city than you
will ever know where they will ever take credit
for they have not failed this city the canister of
purple loses at Police Headquarters I'm bringing
with me the next generation of finely tuned
combat soldiers oh disgusting I've never been
the biggest beep bop and Rocksteady a little goofy
if the purple ooze can turn humans into animals if
properly re-engineered watch this watch this oh
you could turn them into humans it could turn us
humans
change back no man you gotta Embrace who you
are we don't need that kind of change okay
you're right we're American Heroes they
do look a lot better this time around I
know they feel like real characters too yeah
you can't say a word of this to the others
all the ones would be eavesdropping oh my God it's
gonna be a story of acceptance Embrace who you are
it all started with the big bang well I got a big
bang for you that is the worst that's what we do
to be honest they're a little Annoying
I mean is there characters is it
some of the designs do have
this 90s aesthetic that I like
you don't have to be stuck down here forever you
know so Leo told Donnie to keep it a secret uh
no hold on you didn't you didn't answer what are
the three most important traits to the ninja speed
stealth trust and honor where's the honor
and keeping secrets from your brothers oh
we just resolved this immediately okay we're
addressing I don't know what you're talking
about wow so now you're adding lion to the list
it's called compartmentalization of information
well Justified if there's even a chance
that ooze can make us human it's about
what people up there are willing to accept
true acceptance only comes from within
damn he's an actual like leader and what
about Mikey he don't get a vote there's
only one vote that counts in this family mine
that's not a real leader he's gonna have to
have to right there man you benching
me call it what you want what did I do
sorry guys Turtle division from the data
I just collected I'm surmising that what
was inside this thing may help Shredder
open that portal to another dimension
[Laughter] Thanos we can take the elevator
shafts and vents we need you two to stay on
the ground I can't just walk right into Police
Headquarters what are you chicken what are you
calling chicken turtle such an insult so
we're breaking into police headquarters
we need to find someone to sneak you guys
past I'm sorry this performance is so weird
I don't quite like quite get what he's doing
am I just too familiar with like him and
interviews and on Arrow because something
about it feels so artificial [Laughter]
feel real to me we need to find Shredder I
don't know we're not doing I got concerts
it's just the city I'm still trying to figure out
what Casey's like role is in this like what is he
adding to this equation that like the turtles
couldn't do themselves all right I think we'll
find out via this plan thank you for doing this
stuff think about what the city means to all of us
I do like how Donatello's spy Tech
is really coming to play I'm now
Mikey you're marrying them hurrying [Music]
I'm starting to feel like the focus
is going a little all over the place
it's a cowboy
Mikey will be right there
all the cops here both parties
gotta be a normal and it's
heading toward the front door
all the ninjas feel like
Snake Eyes right no seriously
sweet The Boys Are Back wait we're the
good guys why are you afraid of getting a
shot I thought you guys are bulletproof
they're monsters they're not monsters
don't you go oh
awesome awesome Jones you gotta be kidding me
you know the monsters are the greatest threat
to America I can't get them all on the same page
to think with one mind you shouldn't want them
all to think the same it's their different
points of view that make the team strong oh
my God and Splinter's mentoring good leader
guys a good brother accepts it yes I thought
this movie was a minor Improvement this is a
major step up right in everywhere this is an
actual Ninja Turtles yeah even if I didn't have
any familiar with turtles before it's such it's
a much more enjoyable film it looks like our
mutant buddies are headed to Brazil how do
we get there we sneak onto the next cargo
plane from JFK you know of a turtle plane
that's not what happened we
checked its authenticity oh
you should be chasing
there are times where he just slips right into
his Oliver Queen performance oh yeah because
that super important thing you kind of fire
thing to find and we are ready by action
bye they're unusually cartoony yeah we only
have a 30 second window you know the plan
I don't need to shoot I got my balls
I like how the tough ones one is afraid
I cannot get over how much better the visual
effects are it's much more seamless at times
it looks like practical effects much more
seamless and the way that the action scenes
are constructed it's a lot more yeah visually
palatable what would Vin Diesel do look at that
literally thinking to myself too like this is
so fat it's a fast and furious vibes [Laughter]
faster somebody kind of fast
you're gonna make it okay
is that Brian Tyree Henry uh I don't
think so oh I think that was him
the good news is you're wearing shoes the bad news
is I am finding myself though starting to Crave
some of the hand-to-hand martial arts choreography
that the first one offered that's been kind of
missing I feel that way definitely over an
hour into this movie maybe in the the finale
what's going on here [Music]
oh my God he said these morons they're alive
everything is great I'm doing awesome why are you
trying to still Land This Plane just
evacuate it I don't have parachutes
oh we're staying in there okay [Music]
this is insane there's some great shots
though the way they transitioned in and
out of like playing disguise is really
well done oh my God what turtle in water
everyone okay wait where's Raph
got even the flesh look at the texture and
the Flesh on his arm it just looks so real
yeah with the water yeah [Applause] sweet
sauce finally Hot Potato Hot Potato [Music]
characters in movies always find themselves
in these crazy waterfalls [Music] yeah
that's awesome real team effort Leo
quit being man they all tried their
best they were all improvising I don't
the situation they didn't anticipation
Mr Stockman doctored the footage so
I'm betting that there's some sort
of action Dairy feed that will show that he's
been working with shredder I want you to be
the hero that the whole city thinks you are
just hang up enough this hidden camera bingo
okay he's actually starting to feel essential
because there is a point where I was like I
feel like it was sort of perfunctory that they
were like we have to we have to put him in here
their hacking abilities are phenomenal
once it's fully powered the portal will
be just wide enough for the Techno drone to come
through piece by piece this is gonna be insane
he seems like he's having fun
is that what I think it is there it is [Laughter]
alien warship is coming through piece by
piece whoa interesting oh is it assembling
commanding officer goes by the name of I
don't know that guy but I hate that guy
we may be the only ones who can survive around
that portal the only ones who can get close enough
to this Technodrome to shut it down it's like
you were born for this [Laughter] one sip and
we'll stay the same on the inside but look like
humans on the outside no they're not gonna take it
are they I take it I take anything I'm desperate
for drugs I take one that turns me into a turtle
I'll do whatever you guys say but uh
only Ralph gets the vote [Laughter]
there you go
oh [__] out of the Shadows oh yeah [Laughter]
let's just say we're Four Brothers From New York
who hate bullies and love this city nice
and right now we're the city's best hope
we're teenagers we're teenagers bacon egg and
cheese tell her about the arrangement confess
these are your confessions these four are the ones
who took Shredder down the first time I was kind
of more of a wingman we've been doing our part
to protect this city from the Shadows now we're
out of the Shadows into the light we're gonna need
strategy Instinct oh this is cool awesome for the
finale of the last one this is awesome I'll be a
god you'll be just what you've always been a fly
a footnote Oh Oh I thought you
were gonna say anything yeah
no one will ever know who you are
wow Shredder no honor this is like a soft reboot
does he have the the mecca now he's just regular
as an actual outfit this time Death Star Unicron
whoa this is a super Transformers right now
oh god oh this guy is so gross I imagine
this had to be in 3D when it came out in
theater I think so yeah the beacon has been
set and once the Techno drone reassembles
we can rule the planet did they put
black yeah on his face yeah I do not
like to share you betrayed me actually
I barely even thought about you yeah
yeah oh wow what oh that's upsetting that's lame
he's been such a passive villain this whole movie
oh wow oh my God wait slow down
there's probably Easter eggs there oh
no
damn you can feel that all right is
April's makeup intact just tell me
April's makeup is intact let me know she's
okay oh my God she's so hot thank you but
she's still hot it's got a worried
for a second damn oh it's perfect
it's okay she's looking right at me oh
my God does she want me should I leave
[Music]
it's not that bad it's just a
dumb robot there's like some
post-apocalyptic cyberpunk sci-fi Vibe about
it hey Bubblicious let's see what you've got
they've replaced Mecca Shredder with Craig
about 90 seconds before this thing is complete
all you Donny you know I'm looking
forward to enslaving you we're turtles
not tortoises yeah Turtles fight you
don't think I've got plans for this
yeah it says much cooler actions we'll say
wow how would Casey possibly beat them
that's death that's a concussion he's
Oliver Queen [Laughter] he's gonna save
this did you just see rollerblade
oh okay he needs rollerblades
prepare to watch your city
I got it I found the beacon up [Music]
there oh I'll get that Beacon yeah
wow
yeah this is definitely a 3D movie
actually seems great that he has rollerblades
oh stop stop
would that hurt them how you think not
right let me give you a hug goodbye
kiss him give him a little smooch
they're working together where's Mikey nice nice
praying is down but his ship's still building
uh oh I do got some issues with the handling of
crying over all that I wouldn't dive into after
the movie but definitely got some criticisms
close the portal now
way to go Casey
we did it
kind of looks like the timeline from
uh from Loki a little bit I'll be back
a thousand times stronger no you won't this
is the last one it didn't make enough money
it bombed we got something no one else has
garbage truck strong arms Turtle bodies
oh yeah that yeah they got that Cape convicts
Bebop and Rocksteady are now in police custody
while Dr Baxter Stockman remains oh and I guess
Shredder is just in with their ship with another
dimension how did they arrest be pop in Rock City
I present to you the keys to the city a symbol
of our appreciation respect and for our
continued partnership but don't you dare
come out to the light stay in there water
yes freak I think you should give people
more credit I think we'll stick with the
arrangement we've had if you ever need us
April knows where to find us you guys can sign
autographs at Comic-Con now [Music] [Applause]
it's not putting a shot it's not easy putting a
shot like that together the visuals
in here are so much better oh 100
same year as Civil War did it yeah
and they're tired it's a Teenage Ninja Ninja
Turtles turtles in a half shell turtle power
well all right is there a post-credits scene oh
wait if there is a post-credit scene this one you
raise you see it I'll remember all right I might
we'll see all right okay let's see how it goes
um well yeah man yeah uh let's uh let's Chit Chat
Molly's credits are rolling what'd you think man
I thought that was a lot of fun yeah I had a
really good time with it I know there's a lot
of people not happy that we didn't like the first
one but I can genuinely say I enjoyed this one
ratio hell yeah so out of authenticity all those
views it's still like only three percent really
four percent we really had a real issue with us
okay it's the vocal ones all right yeah that's
fine yeah that's fine all right oh God that was
creepy that was a weird Stephen Amell drawing
right there I enjoyed this one significantly
more yeah and I feel like the reaction uh
during their you know because sometimes
there's so much dialogue happening that
there are other thoughts that I want to get out
but part of the thing is like finding the right
spot to give the the additional thoughts uh I
really I could there I did have some criticisms
though but I feel like the compliments about
this movie I feel like I made pretty clear
um because yeah the the directing of it just the
directing and the cinematography was a much more
appealing aesthetic all around to just actually
take in not easy to follow the last one had uh
this weird you know grimy blend of trying to look
gritty realistic and it just ultimately left for
like a uh kind of a dour tone or something like
it was never never really approached naturally fun
whereas this right off the bat had a much better
pace and an energy and felt authentically fun like
I want to do my best to remove myself from what
uh you know over to Ninja Turtles movie should
be and just go with like is this a decent movie or
not you know and I felt that this ultimately was a
decent movie and especially when you compared to
the last one it's it's a significant Improvement
because even if you just look at it as its own
film the things they talk about in the previous
one that are like kind of just throw away lines
are not really fleshed out where it comes to
Ralph's anger they even talk about Leo you're the
leader I never really got that sense in the last
one you know um them as a family and all these
all the things that they talk about that they're
kind of just throw away lines their actual
plot points here in character development for
everyone so just as a film it's it's a much better
movie not everything about it that I really love
um and there are a couple of things really just
one thing in particular that I preferred in the
first one um but yeah those are like my my general
thoughts on it and what did you think about
praying I thought Krang was visually interesting
you know he's like they made an effort to make
him like really grotesque and slimy but
I think ultimately at the end of the day
he was just a physical foil for them to fight
yeah because they didn't really flesh him out
he was literally in one scene in the beginning
and then the end fight and that was it and the
Turtles only just learned about him like a couple
minutes before they find him right right yeah so
it's not this active threat that they're trying to
work to to stop it's just like oh this is what's
happening okay now we have to engage with this
threat that we just learned about so there's no
personal connection towards it and they just are
like we have to stop it because we're heroes and
we're Turtles and that's what we do which is my
problem with the shredder fight in the last movie
yeah there's no personal Stakes involved yeah
those were it's like they just have to fight
Shredder and Shredder is kind of personality
Less in in the last one also the turtles never
see Shredder directly in this one really yeah
I don't think they saw him once on the freeway
I think yeah though uh I would have just been fine
with a rematch instead of instead of this crank
like the crane fight felt very Transformers and
had that Vibe of you know the the wash together
visuals of a bunch of the of the color palette of
the scene but it still looked pretty cool like I
was I was surprised how I was actually enjoying
that sequence because normally the way the the
color aesthetic was would kind of put me off but
that scene still had the I like the shutter speed
the motion effect that they had a lot of those
locked off shots like the POV with uh Michelangelo
skateboarding and whatnot so there's still some
cool visuals and a lot of it kind of did feel
like it was plucked out of an anime and and I and
I think uh crane does look cool but man the second
they uh froze incapacitated Shredder I was like
dad's a lame ass move they actually had a genuine
build up to this they had a real thing and they
just gave him his help they literally just gave
him his help he looked surprisingly cool too and
then immediately gonna freeze him and shovel like
that was [__] they didn't think that through
that was total [__] yeah I will say even though
I wasn't personally invested in the stakes of the
Turtles versus crane sure I will say I liked that
it was it wasn't about necessarily Turtles
versus crane but more so their relationship
with each other working together to stop this
common threat and then coming together in that
Arc which is something I enjoyed yeah there's an
actual Arc here with them you know I think they
definitely swapped out the screen time that
they gave April on the last one to actually
give to the turtles because she is definitely
relegated to being just a supporting character
100 like nowhere near as any of this a personal
Journey for her whatsoever strictly to service
the turtles like if you know I almost forgot she
was a reporter until that thing is yeah yeah sure
like while I uh like I actually I appreciated
the efforts of the first movie doing that
um not like it was like my favorite thing in
the world like I said a more appreciated the
efforts and I like making Fox and I think that
she plays off well with these guys um so yeah
that was that was good crank thing out of the
way uh the yeah yeah the train thing definitely
needs some improvement that was that was my
biggest uh thing that I wanted to harp on okay
I enjoy as a controversial of a figure
Stephen Amell loves to put himself
the his performance here I could not quite
pinpoint what was so odd about it and I couldn't
tell if it was just my own like subjective I
mean it is all subjective but I couldn't tell
if it was just what I I I'm normally pretty good
at divorcing myself from another actor's work even
if I'm very accustomed to a performance that I
saw them do for a very long time I I can I can
definitely appreciate the differences and nuances
of a completely different character yeah and here
it just didn't ring sincere to me at any point uh
with what he was doing with his with his voice and
mannerisms and his never blinking that he loves to
carry I mean I think I think that is just Stephen
Amell I never noticed he's not much of a blinker
um which works for like you know stoic serious
guy you know um but here it was it was odd and I
and I don't really like the character that much
this is where it's going to sound strange
logically I don't like the character that
much like in here there is something weirdly fun
about his performance even though I can you know
intellectualize that there's so much wrong about
this portrayal uh we we talked about it quite a
bit the whole thing with yeah like hockey players
[__] they're just like force in here just like
because they have to work at home this is Casey
Jones so we gotta have it it's it's bizarre um
when he's like fighting the ninjas I hate that he
whooped their asses um that really upset me yeah I
should have pointed that out right away because I
was sort of waiting to see how things would unfold
but that severely undercuts the threat of them
and I probably would have liked Casey Moore if he
actually struggled to fight them yeah versus going
in and weapons The Mask he got beaten thrown into
a car and didn't affect him like in the slime
he's a superhuman he's all over Queen and he's
supposed to be the antithesis to that yeah he's
just like your regular Schmo like your regular
guy you know yeah yeah I think that I don't think
he bothered me like he he did bother me I don't
know to the extent of that you were bothered
but I think it was I don't know I recognize he
was trying to do a different performance with
uh him pitching up his voice but yeah I don't
think it worked per se but I can appreciate his
his energy that he brought to the film though
I don't know he didn't feel entirely necessary
if everything about his character felt obligatory
yeah like he's just like oh we gotta have
him because that's what Ninja Turtles has
Casey Jones even though they're gonna put Casey
Jones and not really making Casey Jones yeah but
you know it was it was fine also the the kind
of half-assed half-baked a romance tease with
him and April O'Neil oh they're both hot they're
both hot so they got to get together yeah that's
what they do in the other properties and they
got to do it what happened to his art to get
respect from his peers yet is it gonna make him
detective after helping save the world probably
not or she's just gonna go play hockey full-on
vigilante nothing happened there and he wore it
one time I'm like what was the point I don't know
why I changed into that yeah it didn't because
nothing about outside of him physically doing
it had anything to do with his character yeah
I was like that's I don't know it was kind of lame
it was lame it was a little lame um the Bebop and
Rocksteady they're supposed to be juvenile
I thought they were annoying of course they
were I I've never really I've never really loved
Bebop and Rocksteady there's nothing I've ever
seen them in I've never read it I've never read
a Ninja Turtles comic but like saying the cartoon
the secret of the actually I prefer kind of
their Secret of the Ooze portrayal order they
can't talk uh but yeah I I don't know I've never
I've never personally been that gravitated towards
them it's weird because obviously crying a CGI
the turtles of CGI and they're CGI but they're
the only part to me that felt like cartoons I
mean crane kind of felt a little cartoony uh
Baxter Stockman did too he was kind of cartoon
he reminded me of um what's his name um Electro
I wonder why like I don't get why they didn't
turn him into the fly they should have turned
them in they were sending that this was definitely
a setup movie for a bigger Universe film yeah and
I never got why they call I called him Sensei
as if he like trained him to fight that's what
you call him I guess so called Mr Shredder
Mr Shredder yeah doctor Shredder Doctor Who
I would call him doctor he's a doctor and
say shredder there's a nice ring to it yeah
I don't know what he does with his time you
know it's been two years since the last one
he went on uh master class and like got his
Doctrine they can do that yeah they're a little
frustrating they still look good though I like
their monstrosity I actually I was enjoying them
before they became the mutants yeah when they
were humans I was enjoying them yeah I thought
his look was very 80s prior to uh was it Bebop
that's the purple one right I think so oh [__]
man they're always a pair I don't know man I
forget the name assignments all the time yeah yeah
that's what I forget it's because they're always
they're always together and I and I constantly
forget which one's Bebop and Rock City again uh
yeah I don't recall well yeah well I think that
I don't know they were they were fine I guess
they didn't really add much to the story but you
know I think that they looked okay also the lift
didn't bother me as much this time on the turtles
I think they toned the lips down they improved the
effects all around on the turtles yeah they looked
more real um I think they did kind of I think
they leaned out Donatello a little bit yeah he
looked very lean that's that's something I also
picked up on this one because they were through
the turtles were the leads and because they got a
lot more screen time I think that in addition to
their their looks their personalities were also
came a lot more distinct well they've done this
one their expressions looked more believable their
textures were felt more tangible there were times
where it would look like practical effects versus
just mocha whereas like in the last one it always
looked like complete CGI to me yeah they only
looked good when they were together in the scenes
by themselves but this time they Blended well
with their environment and they could be in like
right as daylight in the sky yeah you know full
exposure to the Sun and they look great yeah
um so I thought that was a a market Improvement
I do think like while and I thought Leonardo
actually was a felt like a real character here
there are things about like the the pacing and
the overall cacophony of visual stimuli and noise
that can sometimes drown out some of the emotion
that the movie is going for for sure uh but
it bothered me more on the first one though
that's I feel like I would have more gripes with
this movie if I didn't just watch the last one
but this is such an improvement to me that I
appreciate it so much more because I I took
a lot of fault with the last one that that I'm
like no other things here where I'm like yeah the
emotion definitely could have rang a lot bigger
the comedy could have worked better Michelangelo
um was sometimes too dumb to me okay I feel
that sometimes most of the time he's really
dumb though you know he's supposed to be dumb but
when Raphael's like here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go in and do this and Michelangelo's
like wait we're gonna we have a plan we're gonna
go do something I don't get it but he's like all
sometimes the things were like he was too dumb
to me okay wasn't reasonably because again he's
supposed to be the dumb one he's supposed to be
the Cloudy head one supposed to be the Airhead uh
and the stoner one of the group yeah um sometimes
it was like the I don't know I also I could have
used more uh more splinter in the movie he they
use him very sparingly and I think he looked a
lot better than he did in the other one because
I feel like he had like it was just like skin and
then hair yeah like he looks like he grew his hair
out he was on some uh some hair club on this one
what I what I will say that I did really and I did
point it out but I really did miss I thought the
martial arts of the first one was pretty awesome
I can agree with that and it is almost completely
absent here a lot like a lot of time it does if
when it's here it doesn't shine and it's there's
barely there especially it was just kind of weird
to consider that they have markedly more ninjas
this time around uh but they didn't feel at all
like ninjas yeah they didn't put them in scenarios
two B ninjas and also they didn't yes they didn't
try to heighten their freakishly enormous strength
this time around well just their hand to hang the
fights are like not there you know like there's
no like as while I enjoyed the the visual big
the set pieces a lot here especially uh yeah
I enjoyed the I enjoyed the set pieces a lot
like I I think you can call Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles like you you kind of need the ninja aspect
of them and it's not here and that's the biggest
that's the one thing I'm like oh if you just had
like the actual Marsh Casey Jones got to do more
martial arts choreography than they did yeah and
that's a real disappointing part to me because
that was the only thing that was really missing
to me and I I like the I like the punches and
the kicks of the last one quite a bit uh even
when because when the movie wasn't working for me
that and the last one that was really working for
me and I don't know why they completely eliminated
that here um but yeah I wish that was here still
though I mean I'd still take this movie any day
over the last one I could I could watch this movie
and enjoy it it's it's genuinely fun has a good
heart um the color the the whole visual appeal is
is so much something more that I personally just
gravitate towards much more and other than some
disappointing choices that they made I thought
overall was a market Improvement and a right
direction for something that ultimately didn't pan
out yeah yeah it sucks because yeah the last one
the first one was so poorly received that no one
showed up for the second one and after watching
this one I'm like sadly I would have watched one
I would have never been changed a direction like
yeah I'd be down for a third movie see where
they go I kind of wish I would have saw this in
3D because I feel like they really put an effort
into like making three-dimensional yeah and I'm
like yeah I'm going to have been curious to see
what they look like in theaters but I didn't go
on to see it because I didn't care at the time but
I care now and I'm sad we won't get a third one
but hey we got new Turtles now and they're better
yeah that's what I hear ladies and gentlemen what
did you think about this movie do you prefer it
over the first leave your thoughts down below
did you wish we got a third subscribe
leave a like and Hey listen to the patreon
Lance door they talk about the turtles being
heroes in a half show well you are a full show
my friend because Lance store is a real life hero
he's a firefighter he goes out there and he saves
lives daily sometimes he just breaks into people's
homes evacuates them even if there's not a fire
once in a while toaster might go off oh overcook
The Bagel a little too long smoke hit the fire
alarm mom walks in the kitchen goes oh let me just
fan this out a little bit boom land store breaks
that door in with an ax goes we're getting you the
hell out of here lady happens all the time there's
been a lot of reports about people wanting to fire
Lance a lot of the city in the part of Canada that
lives have personally requested to their mayor
that they remove him from participating in the
law enforcement of being a firefighter yet Lance
remains because even once he was fired once he
was terminated from being a firefighter he found
a way to hide inside the firefighting station so
he could still perch his way onto the back
of the firefighting trucks and participate
whenever there's a cat in a tree that the
firefighters have to set up a ladder for to
go take them take the cat off there's Lance with
a hose to shoot that cat down with a big blast
of water many cats have died and Canada due to
Lance's overreaching willingness to be a hero but
yeah thanks Lance
[Music]